was sich da in der wir leben man
negative pulsiert tag und nacht der
hamburger hafen an kulturstätte
wirtschaftsmotor und sehnsuchtsort
bleibe ich
wer begleiten schweizer und
schweizerinnen den der metropole am
wasser leben und arbeiten
mal mit dem strom mal gegen den wind sie
alle sind an die elbe gekommen um hier
ihr glück zu finden
der hafen ist sie weit mehr als ein
arbeitsplatz er ist abenteuer reimer und
hoffnung auf ein anderes leben noch dort
oben im norden
er verbindet die stadt mit der ganzen
welt ist einer der wichtigsten
umschlagplätze für europa aber auch ein
begehrtes wohnviertel der hamburger
hafen wenige meter vom wasser entfernt
hat der intendant der hamburgischen
staatsoper
georges delnon eine neue heimat gefunden
der erste mal ja auch fische
kaffeemaschinen linie arbeiten wollte
ich doch schon schnell nur arbeitet gern
seit zwei jahren ist der intendant der
staatsoper hamburg
und er hat sich einiges vorgenommen
mahlers achte sinfonie inszeniert in der
elbphilharmonie als event mit einer
lichtinstallation er wohl einen impuls
setzen etwas wagen und ausprobieren
das kennen die uns andere aufmerksamkeit
und aufmerksamkeit im job wichtiger und
wenn mit ihr natürlich jetzt durch
die eröffnung ist es natürlich umso
spannender denn was für projekte
realisiert aber natürlich mit denen auch
um so streng damit oder wie jetzt gerade
über die akustik mit diskutiert wird und
was hat assauer was kann insofern hoffe
das macht jetzt rb trocknet sie geschirr
stellen hat der jobangebote aus berlin
und anderen städten
die entschied sich für hamburg eine
wichtige rolle dabei hat die
anziehungskraft der elbphilharmonie
gespielt mit denen hamburg neues
entsteht das gefühl hier und so viele
mythen einfach geplatzt völlig voll und
so viel wie jetzt in die elbphilharmonie
mandantin esprit minute sie meter
trennen
mit drehen und es ist traurig stanley
wieso ein heiligtum und novartis
ausprobieren um liegt super das ist
großartig
das konzerthaus ist ein besuchermagnet
doch nur wenige haben den großen saal
für sich allein
zum ersten mal wird vorstellung heute
mit seinen leuten das lichtkonzept der
installation überprüfen ohne orchester
in aller ruhe denn schon mal das
generalprobe es ist ungefähr saal ich tu
dir das vorstellst oder wir haben ja
gesagt na wir wollen die sache ein
bisschen trennen lassen
es muss dunkel seien im prinzip wir
sagen ja auch das hat eine visuelle
komponente der wie so lecker aber das
ist vielleicht nicht ganz dunkel ist im
theater fände ich auch okay aber ist ja
von ist ja schon gegeben durch den
stufen und durch durch das streulicht
und so das würde mich interessieren wie
wie stark es so die maximalen stimmungen
sind
kann ich das mal sehen das war super
es ist brauch überhaupt nicht den
schwarzen bühnenraum linien
das hat eine ganz eigenständige kraft
nicht aber das ist so das hellste oder
heller werden wenn die händler werden
wir nicht da ist an die leistungsgrenze
dieser led
ich habe dann müssen wir den rest dem
anpassen
dann müssen wir mit dem rest so dunkel
dass das leuchtet ja das ist okay für
mich abgesehen was ich wollte ja
manchmal weiter ich hab das jetzt machen
kann mir vorstellen dass es auch viele
leute nicht wissen will warum
berufsarmee
aber das kann mit der kunst verschrieben
frage ich glaube da muss man mutig sie
und eintrag glaube dass es die richtige
idee ist im richtigen moment am
richtigen ort
die elbphilharmonie thront das neues
wahrzeichen mitten im hamburger hafen
umgeben von frachtschiffen und
kaianlagen hinter der köhlbrandbrücke
liegt einer der weltweit modernsten
containerterminals das frachtschiff
chicago express wird gleichzeitig be und
entladen
in hamburg sollen insgesamt 5000
container von bord
fast alle arbeitsschritte wurden
automatisiert doch auf die lasche kann
man nicht verzichten
sie lösen die verankerung der container
in handarbeit unter den ställen
transportbehältern ist auch ein
container mit laufschuhen für das
schweizer unternehmen an
hergebracht hat den kapitän alexander
meier noch einen tag war an bord und
übergabe zu regeln dann endlich kann er
nach hause
drei monate lang war er an bord und ist
um die halbe welt gefahren in vietnam
hat er die laufschuhe an bord genommen
einmal nach langem bangen thailand dann
funkt vietnam dann runter nach singapur
von der ausweisung nach sri lanka
colombo als hafen dann durchs rote meer
durch den suezkanal dieses schiff schon
öfters fahren hat durchs mittelmeer
durch wir zurück nach rotterdam und
danach
jetzt sind wir hier wie in hamburg nach
92 tagen und knapp 28.000 500 seemeilen
zurückgelegt haben
in diesen drei monaten 6000 laufschuhe
langen in container des schweizer
unternehmens an
inzwischen werden 98 prozent solcher
schuhe in asien produziert und per
schiff nach europa transportiert
vollautomatische transportfahrzeuge
bringen den container nun an eine
festgelegte position auf dem lagerplatz
eine logistische meisterleistung
jährlich gehen von hier aus 58.000
solcher container in die schweiz auf die
laufschuhe für onboard jetzt die letzte
etappe ihrer weltreise die terminals
befinden sich südlich der elbe auf der
anderen seite des flusses liegen die
wohnviertel der millionenstadt ottensen
das szeneviertel mit elf zugang gilt das
hip hier mitten im herzen des quartiers
wohnt sarah lisa schrey blick die
zürcherin schaut häufig im eck café dem
yuma krönchen vor bei einer schweizer
konditorei
und saralisa frisch nach hamburg gezogen
war hat sie zeitweise in jener krönchen
gejobbt ist ganz okay und das ist alles
so friedlich findest du für dieses mega
ganz prima consulting irgendwie für
grund erhält sind wir durch steinschlag
gemacht und deswegen damit dass laufen
wir haben es mit der schlafbrille kann
man am schluss vorgeschichte nicht
machbar besser wäre
dann dort ganz fertig danke film
konzentrieren
bis bald geht es los
heute will saralisa an ihrer
journalistenkarriere arbeiten mit ihrem
mann frank geht es auf recherche tour
mehr organisieren
das ist eine herzige prozess ziemlich
fertigmacht hamburg vom wasser aus
entdecken und es gab es darum ist er
verschiedene carlo tura hamacher und
halten wir sind die stadt von einer
anderen perspektive und spricht mit ganz
vielen ebenen und ich bin einer zeit
geführt also ich mache mich sehr
interessiert haben lässt autfahrer
recherchiere und mit mancher werde und
gleichzeitig geht mir das herz auf text
der artikel wurde vom szene hamburg
magazin beauftragt ein wichtiger schritt
für die ausgebildete journalistin die
sich als freie autorin etablieren will
letztes jahr hat sarah lisa ihre
berufliche karriere etwas schleifen
lassen und hauptsächlich als barfrau im
hafenviertel gejobbt
[Musik]
die windrichtung passt heute ganz gut zu
eurer route weil ihr es ging an paddelt
nur dann fällt der rückblick ein
bisschen leichter
bis hier oben und dann könnt ihr hier
hochfahren und dafür wo der rote stern
ist da ist das fährhaus
vielen dank
bis später
[Musik]
auch thomas gisiger von der zweiten
heimat ist heute am wasser unterwegs für
ihn ist der hafen ein ort der
inspiration für sein theater und sein
persönlicher ankerplatz wir legen manche
hin angeklagte proben ist nach dem
rauchen heitz co
also eine heimweh spitze aber mit dem
kataster für die menschen in deutschland
ist bewusst dass wir im theater
es gibt er freimütig machte familie und
soll natürlich daheim und wenn man nicht
so sauber wie gewünscht aber ich hab
dann kann man es ehrlich gesagt noch als
ich für mich ist es schon extrem sie
schon sagen aber hamburgischen
alternative um jetzt haben wir wieder
zurück
die elbe ist eine wichtige verkehrsader
auch für den öffentlichen
personentransport fairen bringen jeden
tag tausende menschen zu arbeiten denn
platz auf der elbe teilen sie sich mit
riesigen containerschiffen aus aller
welt
[Musik]
also ich bin ja überhaupt kein techniker
schicken
aber wie begeistert dass deren maße ich
weiß gar nicht was das wirklich glauben
wir so ein bisschen wie soll mein
kinderzimmer wo man irgendwie spürt oder
früchte vor dem but one oder kran ich
weiß dass ich noch mal einfach so alles
in dimensionen ist wie man das im hafen
hamburg sei die elbe wie eine bühne auf
der jeden tag ein neues stück aufgeführt
wird
das ist ja das tolle da natürlich der
elbe das alles so extrem hoch ist also
die geschichte um normale fluss so gar
nicht fördert die kurse harnisch und war
selbst solle ich finde ich am hamburger
hafen
der hessische wohn und schaffen sich so
extrem noch ne also der ob es die ganze
welt wohnen auch gerade am hafen also
nicht einfach um eine industrie
hofstelle sich hat glaubt die stadt mit
und was bitte ganz verliebt vom sv
dassow eines schiffs oder queen mary
mehr oder weniger mit rund 800.000
passagiere fahren jedes jahr für
kreuzfahrtschiffe die elbe hoch oder
runter
für thomas gisiger ist das ein optimales
stoff für sein neues theaterstück
inspiriert haben ihn die erzählungen
seiner mutter die kreuzfahrten zu zweit
verbrachte sie allein an deck weil ihr
partner sie krank wurde
zunächst stellen das für mich auch nicht
so frei plätze eine riesengroße schiff
von der anlage und sagen und somit
zusammen machen und setzt sich nun
plötzlich ganz ganz allein
zusammen mit einer musikerin bastl
thomas bereits an der dramaturgie und
andere musikauswahl
heute morgen hatte ich war ein stück
geschickt
ja
[Musik]
für geduld denn der elbphilharmonie
keine zeit vor der generalprobe des
orchesters herrscht reges treiben im
großen saal
jetzt wird sich zeigen ob musik und
licht harmonisch zusammen passen eine
gratwanderung denn die installation soll
zur geltung kommen ohne dass die musiker
geblendet werden
venedig wie haben montieren wir haben
beleuchtet
ich habe finde ich eine gute lösung ich
muss aber sicher sein dass niemand von
euch geblendet wird
es kann nicht generell nicht gut sagen
man kann da oder dann noch vor ihnen
habe ich habe extra auf die contra beste
mehr gegeben ich habe extra mehr darauf
hafen gegeben ich habe so gemacht dass
er die gesichter sieht weil er gesagt
hatte wieder ein gesicht
aber so dass das projekt hinsicht noch
stimmt
hallo ich hoffe das ist für sie so gut
wir haben noch mehr licht auf euch
gegeben
außerhalb jeglicher beläuft ja deshalb
bei mir extra aus
sie würden wenn sie ein bisschen nach
oben um sie blenden das geht nicht
werden sie ja wir müssen da einmal durch
glaube ich nun einmal durch indem es
gern noch ein bisschen zurück nicht nur
die licht diskussion sorgt für aufregung
dirigent kent nagano mit dem song
stellen und das projekt entwickelt hat
ist krank geworden und fällt aus
innerhalb kürzester zeit muss sein
ersatzmann gefunden werden
[Musik]
einfach im schrank steht für der aktien
der serbe forschung mal der 18
ich hatte sehr viel zu organisieren
können dort ist zwischen dadurch dass
alles erkennen sind
für das system rote haar und dem volk
[Applaus]
für nagano springt der 81 jährige
israelische dirigent eliahu inbal 1
bis zur premiere bleibt nur noch wenig
zeit
[Musik]
auch auf der anderen elbseite herrscht
angespannte konzentration jede stunde
die ein container schiff am kai liegt
kostet die reederei viel geld nur 30
stunden dauert es bis die chicago
express ent und wieder beladen ist in
dieser zeit regelt kapitän alexander
meier die formalitäten wahrscheinlich
wenn die 22 uhr fertig dass wir zwischen
30 auslaufen bei dem tiefgang wird das
niedrigwasser ist
samstag 13 an diesen terminen
funktioniert das löschen und laden der
containerschiffe weitgehend
computergesteuert große teile des areals
sind für menschen komplett gesperrt
der container mit den laufschuhen für
die schweiz ist auf dem weg zum hafen
bahnhof
das logistikunternehmen kühne & nagel
mit sitz in der hafencity organisiert
den transport für den
sportschuhhersteller von vietnam bis in
die schweiz
robbie kruse ist verkehrsleiter für den
container import überwacht den gesamten
streckenverlauf die ware geht ja von ho
chi minh stadt bis nach hamburg per
seeschiff das heißt unsere kollegen
buchen das entsprechende seeschiff die
seereise steht an der container muss
hier letztendlich in hamburg wenn er
eintrifft soll technisch abgewickelt
werden wir kümmern uns um die komplette
kommunikation und letzten endes um den
bahntransport von hamburg bis nach basel
letzten endes nicht schweiz deswegen
sitzen wir hier und drücken alle
positionen knöpfchen schneller die
information zu haben weil sie können
sich vorstellen so ein kunde der sich
natürlich auf heißen kohlen erwartet
natürlich auf die ware der erwartet auch
von uns dass wir die ware wirklich zum
richtigen zeitpunkt am richtigen ort
liefern knapp 53.000 kilometer haben die
schuhe im container auf see schon hinter
sich und die letzte etappe in die
schweiz
legen sie nun auf der schiene zurück
in 48 stunden werden sie ihr ziel
erreichen
während des ladevorgangs muss nur eine
kernmannschaft der besatzung an bord
bleiben
der kapitän wird heute abgelöst und darf
nach drei monaten auf see wieder nach
hause ich bin damit aufgewachsen groß
geworden ich mag meinen job ich liebe
ihn so zu sagen und es ist schön wenn
man jemand hat zuhause die das genauso
sieht vorher zusteht und auch klar kommt
wenn man halt drei monate lang nicht zu
hause ist das schwieriger man kann
natürlich unterstützen heutzutage und
nie mehr telefonieren aber die
persönliche sache die fehlt halt und
dann muss auch der partner musste auch
schon sehr stark für sein ihre knie
klaus vor über ein halbes jahrhundert zu
sehen so lange für seine ehe zerbrach
die seefahrer rileys den 73-jährigen
trotzdem nicht los
heute lebt er im seemannsheim am
hamburger hafen
an seinen ersten besuch in der
hansestadt kann er sich noch genau
erinnern
pro kalendermonat lebe unter dem
quartier machen für diesen blick und
shoppen und so süß könnte dass sie viele
lytro wo pflegende bis lied zu ihr und
natürlich die dame vor ort in 123 keine
haupt sind nicht so viel damit damit sie
aber sexy sind 54
aber diese show verbandes sie mit dem
boban oder zimmermann und kabel gast
und ich glaube sie dahin gestellt
damit sieht und ja wenn wir land und der
hamburg nutzt mit der russin ist als
kritischer denn eine faschings an
heutzutage sehen die besatzungen kaum
noch etwas von den städten die ihre
schiffe anlaufen
die kurzen liegezeiten im hafen machen
es unmöglich nur die seemanns clubs bei
den terminals bieten den
schiffsbesatzungen etwas abwechslung
jörg niklaus ist auf dem weg zum club
totalen er überlegt die einrichtung als
ehrenamtlicher helfer zu unterstützen
für den alten kapitän ist der besuch wie
eine reise in die eigene vergangenheit
[Musik]
zu viel
im druck halten können die seeleute das
nötigste einkaufen überweisungen tätigen
oder mit einem guten wlan-netz ihre
liebsten zu hause anrufen
alle weltreligionen stellvertretend in
einem raum
ihr macht eigentlich alles bereit muss
nun annehmen
wir sind wirklich aufgehen das ist ein
ding das da unten auf ebenen weg sondern
es macht man diesen weg auf eine
himmelsleiter auf hoher see sind die
menschen aufeinander angewiesen das
erfordert toleranz gerade bei themen wie
politik und religion
das steht im vordergrund was glaubst du
sondern es ist die russische matrosen du
machst job und frauen den muslimen und
den massstab gespielt oder von bodman
stuhl war jedoch verlangen front
religion ungeordnet jedenfalls nicht
bekämpft und und und und lange gestellt
nach religion einer noch kreditwürdig
kapitän jack nicklaus möchte für die
jungen leute da sein und sie führen ihre
heimat unterstützen
der druckdaten ist der perfekte ort
dafür für die matrosen ein heimathafen
auf zeit bevor ihr schiff in wenigen
stunden wieder ausläuft
hamburg hat mehr brücken als venedig und
unzählige wasserstraßen genau die will
saralisa für ihren zeitschriftenartikel
erkunden
doch zunächst muss das neu erworbene
aufblasbare kajak getauft werden und
allzeit gute fahrt
saralisa und frank vor fast zwei jahren
in hamburg geheiratet haben waren
freunde und familie überrascht doch die
beiden wollten öffentlich bekunden wie
ernst sie es meinen mit ihrem neuen
heimathafen hamburg
[Musik]
die mittelschwere hat die chance symbol
produzieren als symbol dafür sage ok hat
eine mannschaft mit dem oder mitläufer
verbringen und sensorische wir bis 50
cent nicht nötig ich schieße
konventionen
man muss über jahrzehnte stand referate
und verstand für immer um so also ich
finde das passt dann passt voll passt
und fast immer noch glaube dass für mich
hat er das rein symbolcharakter
tatsächlich und es ist eine ganz große
aussage ganz glatt wie das klingt man
muss ja frauen sarah lisa genießt es die
recherche tour für ihren artikel mit
frank zusammen machen zu können
mit dem kajak erkunden sie die dose elbe
die noch zum hamburger stadtgebiet
gehört eine von vier paddeltouren für
sara lee saß artikel bei der recherche
stößt sie auf relikte aus deutschlands
dunkler vergangenheit in hamburg mit dem
boot zum das krasse dayton ist dass der
alte kanal data gefangene wie christus
krabbe wurde nicht also ein kotelett hat
nicht nur dort sondern wenn mein partner
hat also das stück geschichte also stück
schreckliche geschichte aber ein stück
geschichte machen beim kz aleker und
gedanke steht cargo ag zum beispiel habe
es ein bisschen probiert mit torres als
40 verschiedene interessen abdecken also
natur mal sport mal drei wochen hat
saralisa noch zeit dann muss ihr artikel
fertig sein
zurück in ottensen der zweiten heimat
von thomas gisiger und andreas vor 150
jahren gehörte der stadt seien noch zu
dänemark heute ist ottensen ein
multikulturelles viertel hamburg in der
zweiten heimat macht thomas gisiger
klarschiff der theater betreiber nutzt
die zeit im frühsommer und ordnung zu
schaffen und sein neues stück zu
entwickeln das man einfach extrem unter
druck die produktion
ich hoffe dass wir das machen sollen im
sommer blut mache ganz entspannt und
damit so entspannt war günter super
das heißt mit anderen worten die ganze
sitzung noch gedanken und dann haben wir
aber so ganz viele medien mit der lebens
oder gedanke hat mich jemand direktor
für mich vergisst so ganz schnell bietet
und dann kritiken war gelogen damit
meistens meter über die noch hinter
sortieren und was mir bestimmt schmeißt
sie backen die anderes aber nachher
solche minimale überlappungen nach es
ist neue stücke des 17 zuschlag für die
eigentlich dass sie den höchsten
vorletzte woche
gh die große liebe zu seiner frau
das ist ja dass ich heute morgen im
sternenhimmel one über hat also die zwei
finger darauf sitzt schief gehen die
macher oder sie 420 kilo das ist was
ganz besonderes machen so wie es ganz
überlegt auch machen natürlich und das
ist natürlich für geschäft ganz weg das
mit ganz beliebig stewart erstmals aber
man soll das status report was nachher
fluss passiert ja ganz andere geschichte
damit werden muss das immer vor der miss
http www.thomas eine ausbildung zum
dekorations gestalter gemacht doch dann
zog es ihn an eine clown schule und
später als familien auf ein
kreuzfahrtschiff
in der zweiten heimat ist thomas für den
kreativen part zuständig zusammen mit
seinem lebenspartner andreas der sich um
die finanzen kümmert aber auch sein
wichtigster kritiker ist
die zwei männer ergänzen sich ideal als
unternehmer aber auch als fan also es
gibt manchmal so dass wir im eifer des
gefechts uns vielleicht ein bisschen
anzicken das kommt vor
aber das ist dann für den moment und das
ist im nächsten moment auch schon wieder
vergessen und es hätte mit dem schaf
stewart hätten wir ganz genau und wenn
es dann zu viel wird dann können wir uns
gegenseitig nicht mehr ernst nehmen dann
müssen wir anfangen zu lachen und dann
ist das aus ist ist die luft wieder raus
also das ist und daniel also streiten
uns jetzt 20 jahre
wir haben uns einmal heftig gestritten
das ist glaube ich 17 jahre her und
seitdem nicht wieder also das ist
verlorene lebenszeit die elbe teilt
hamburg in nord und süd der tunnel unter
dem fluss ist das nadelöhr der stadt
auch ursula riechen berger macht diese
tour an jedem arbeitstag
schon auf der nordseite helfen und muss
auf die südseite wenn da ist das
hafenmuseum und da ist auch der richtige
hafen
wir fahren hier jetzt gerade am
container-terminal waltershof vorbei und
sehen auch grad wie hier
containerschiffe geladen und gelöscht
werden
und in diesem hafengebiet ist mein
arbeitsort die schweizerin leitet das
hafenmuseum hamburg es liegt dem größten
zusammenhängenden gewerbegebiet
deutschlands schweizer finden sich hier
nur wenige es rinnt mir halt heimischer
wenn sie zutiefst soll es gibt in rafah
und im umfeld kein schweizer mehr honig
schmeckt werde und es ist so dass ich
schon sehr lange in deutschland bin bin
als kind schon nach deutschland gekommen
und da hat es sich dann doch sehr
schnell verloren und der schwester von
ihr lebt in luzern
und wenn ich die besucher dann freue ich
mich wenn es nach ein paar tagen wieder
kommt und ja es sich für mich wieder
ganz natürlich anhört schwyzerdütsch zu
schwätze
es ist nach wie vor meine heimat da
fühle ich mich zu hause fühle ich mich
geborgen
das war auch nie für mich eine
fragestellung will ich die deutsche
staatsangehörigkeit annehmen sondern ich
bin und bleibe schweizerin der
arbeitsplatz der 47-jährigen leiterin
des hafen museums ist der schuppen 50a
ein altes lagerhaus im ehemaligen
freihafen gelände
[Musik]
nein schön dass er heute da bist mein
ist die sigrid hallo der hafen hat seine
eigenen gesetze
ein wort ein handschlag zählen so viel
wie ein vertrag
warum muss ich einmal meinen dienst
handy raus holen ohne dass ich hilflos
bin so haben wir gerade noch ein modell
geschenkt bekommen gestern hier das ist
ein modell der passat eine viermastbark
von der hamburger reederei und ja so ist
mein schreibtisch nicht nur einen
arbeitsplatz sondern irgendwie auch jan
lagerorten depot und muss zusehen dass
ich irgendwie den typen noch freihalten
kann
viele exponate aus einer zeit als der
hafen noch nicht computergesteuert war
befinden sich unter freiem himmel
die kulturwissenschaftlerin übernimmt
häufig ausrangierte geräte aus dem hafen
um sie restaurieren zu lassen
rund 150 ehrenamtliche hafen senioren
helfen ihr dabei
viele senioren haben ihr ganzes
arbeitsleben lang im hafen oder auf
schiffen verbracht männer wie thomas
können maschinen bedienen von denen die
jungen hafenarbeiter meist kann
wir haben knapp etwas unter einem war er
noch nicht in betrieb braucht natürlich
ein bisschen zeit zur stunden ungefähr
bisschen von raumtemperatur den zur
dampfentwicklung hand und danach geht es
ein bisschen zügiger
noch immer nicht viel druck eine welt
aus stahl und rost und
unterschiedlichsten gerüchen die luft im
hafen schmeckt nach mehr diesel pfeffer
und kakao und nach der weiten welt
nirgendwo sonst in der hansestadt
prallen so viele lebenswelten und
kulturen aufeinander wie hier mehr als
150.000 menschen in der region arbeiten
direkt oder indirekt im hamburger hafen
immer mehr von ihnen im kulturbereich
der sich längst zu einem weiteren
wachstumsmotor entwickelt hat in der
elbphilharmonie herrscht nervosität
heute abend feiert gustav mahler sind
von jeder 1000 mit mehr als 300 musikern
und sängern premiere
auch intendant vorstellung ist
angespannt es vom publikum wird jetzt
mit der idee von eigene licht sport wo
man dazu bereit
ist es normal bis amt ist und pathetisch
und emotional normaler pc
das ist für mich die spanische meinte
david wie wir als kollektiv hier kurz
vor der aufführung fehlt immer noch ein
entscheidender mann
er ist noch nicht da
dirigentin ball ist noch nicht
aufgetaucht
aber mit rechts hier alles her
hallo die spatzen
nehmen sie den ganzen glaube ich immer
wollte euch sicher einzigen oder
richtige euch nicht der einzige spitze
sind ist ja dieser pott wo europa damit
sinkt in eine ganz tolle idee ich könnte
wiesen ist sehr typisch für die zeit auf
120 jahrhunderte an den zahlen hinter
stimme richtig entdeckt als musikalische
form und die finger waldseer kinder vor
[Musik]
und dann trifft endlich auch der
dirigent ein alles gut
alles gut alles gut alles gut
er ist da
[Musik]
schuld und ja könnt brauchen wenn die
energie haben muss ist jetzt betrage
solist auf litogo jetzt damit
während das war wichtig dass sie die
energie hand und ich hab da einfach
bequem machen und und zur lösung so
leute
der große saal ist restlos ausverkauft
wie immer
dann kommen die mitwirkenden chöre das
philharmonische staatsorchester hamburg
namhafte solisten und der dirigent
[Applaus]
[Musik]
während die gäste in der 11
mahlers achte genießen herrscht einige
hundert meter entfernt geschäftiges
treiben
die beladung der chicago express ist
beendet die besatzung wartet auf
hochwasser damit sie auslaufen kann
[Musik]
kurz vor mitternacht ist es soweit die
chicago express liegt ab und begibt sich
voll beladen auf die nächste reise rund
um den globus
in zwei monaten wird sie zurückkehren
mit neuer ware auch für die schweiz
[Musik]
abgangs für ein gelungenes experiment
das publikum ist begeistert und
intendant nicht wie entspannt und wird
spannend ist die weitere reaktion das
ist mit sicherheit das ist für alle
hätten sehr begeistert sie und ihr die
handtasche mit handy können auf haben
ist immer so das ist für mich das was
hat sie alle sehen wir bis zu setzen
dass wo eine lichtspur zusätzlich leid
so als als angepeilt
das ist ein dank an den start kommen hat
wir und dann der siag studiert hat man
es in mainz an die damen und herren des
goldenen statue und an die hamburger als
nach schwarzen gemeinsam haben sie es
geschafft in nur drei proben mit der
neuen dirigenten und mit mehr als 300
mitwirkenden in der elbphilharmonie wird
heute noch lange gefeiert im hamburger
hafen der niemals schläft
in der nächsten folge musicaldarsteller
juliano mer cooly tanzt im hafen
doch sein engagement läuft aus seine
zukunft ist unsicher
es ist hafengeburtstag saralisa wegs
auch st pauli und trifft frank in der
korea intendant georges delnon auch
einen die popkultur szene der straße und
picknick mit thomas gisiger und andreas
während der parade ich mein leben lang
hamburg er segnet man länger dieses
hamburg hamburg